Mark Fischbach, better known as Markiplier,
is one of the biggest YouTube stars in the
world, with over 16 million subscribers.
But while all his fans are familiar with his
high energy reactions in his Let's Play videos,
there's actually a lot more to him than just
shouting and playing games.
Here are eight things the world needs to know
about Markiplier.
Regular guy
Before he became one of the internet's most
famous personalities, Markiplier was just
a regular dude.
Born in Honolulu, Hawaii, he studied engineering
at the University of Cincinnati.
But he didn't end up graduating, instead using
his engineering skills to dominate building
games like Poly Bridge while entertaining
his fans.
Sounds like a win-win.
He taught Jimmy Kimmel the ropes
Late night show personality Jimmy Kimmel once
said that he thought that watching Let's Play
videos was a waste of time.
After the internet ganged up on him, Kimmel
invited Markiplier and fellow Let's Play star
MissesMae to teach him the ropes and explain
just what he was missing.
"Hey, will you tell the people, not to kill
me?"
"No."
"No.
No."
We're still waiting for Kimmel's own Let's
Play channel to launch, but this seems like
a pretty good start anyway.
He's afraid of mannequins
Like most people, there are things out in
the world that scare Mark.
More specifically, mannequins and dolls give
him a major case of the heebie-jeebies.
"Hun.
Why are they all staring at me?
That is unsettling.
Get away.
Oh no.
Why are they all staring at me?
Creepy creepy creepy."
That may not sound like a big deal, but as
anyone who watches his channel knows, mannequins
and dolls seem to appear a lot more often
in video games than you might expect.
Which is great for our entertainment, but
not so great for Markiplier's anxiety levels.
"AHHHH!
GET OUT OF HERE GET OUT OF HERE!
OH NO!
GET OUT OF HERE!
OH NO"
Margarita Man
Mark was presented with a Taco Trophy — an
object that we envy deeply — by Rachael
Ray, for having created an amazing margarita.
Turns out that Markiplier once worked as a
bartender, which explains why he's so familiar
with how to make a great one, knowledge he
shared with his thirsty fans.
"And you don't need to add a lot of zest to
it.
You just need to make one, and garnish it,
because presentation is 50% of everything."
He took a hiatus
Mark took a brief hiatus from YouTube following
the death of a close friend of his, Daniel
Kyre.
Daniel was part of Cyndago, a comedy group
on YouTube that focused on dark humor, usually
of satirical nature.
Daniel reached out to Mark to collaborate
with him on projects, and they ended up becoming
roommates and close friends.
On September 18, 2015, Kyre passed away from
brain damage after an attempted suicide.
"Daniel, was such an influence on what we
did.
He was such an inspiration for what I did.
Mark went dark on YouTube for a about a month
before returning to his work.
Misery loves company
This might cause you to look away in abject
horror, but Mark has joint hypermobility in
his legs, meaning that he can move his knees
beyond their normal range, as though he just
got hit with a sledgehammer by Kathy Bates.
As far as party tricks go, this one is downright
repulsive, but you also kind of can't look
away once he starts doing it.
"Zoinks!"
The Snapchat incident
In 2015, a fan claimed that Mark had abused
his power of celebrity and exploited her for
nude photos on the popular app Snapchat, screenshotting
a topless photo that she accidentally sent
to him.
Mark later denied the allegations, claiming
that the fan had continually sent him nude
photos despite his requests that she stop,
and that he never took a screenshot of any
of them.
The incident resulted in Markiplier quitting
Snapchat for good.
It's just a banana
For April Fool's Day 2016, Mark uploaded a
video titled "Mark Contemplates a Banana for
5 Minutes."
The joke apparently was that he is so popular,
he could literally post anything at all and
people would still watch.
Well, the joke's on us, because he's been
proven right, as more than two and a half
million people have watched him watch that
banana.
No spoilers, it still hasn't done anything
particularly appealing.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!